Music: The Night We Met - Lord Huron
Hey.
(Cheering)
Hannah, I am not going, not now,
not ever.
Why didn't you say this to me when I was alive?
Music: Game of Survival - Ruelle
My husband and I,
we never got a note.
(Music)
Hey it's Hannah, Hannah baker.
Oh Shit.
Settle in, because about to tell you the story of my life.
More specifically why my life ended,
and if you're listening to this tape,
you're one of the reasons why
(Music) "This is a wild game of survival"
Is Hannah telling the truth?
Don't believe everything you hear.
Whatever Hannah thought she saw,
She lied about it on those tapes
'cus she's a crazy drama queen,
who just killed herself for attention.
Hannah has secrets Mrs Baker.
Hannah's secrets are what killed her.
Maybe I'll never know why you did
what you did
But I can make you understand
how it felt.
You don't know the whole story!
What else do I need to know?
You're just like the rest of them,
But I'm not.
Everyone is just so nice until they drive
you to kill yourself,
and sooner or later truth will come out.